.
Thank you.
The time being 930, I would call to order the public hearing on House Bill 1038, an act naming a bridge in Londonderry in honor of Robert J.
Prowse.
And I would call on the sponsor, Representative Woods, to speak about the bill.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair, and thank you, Committee, for allowing me to present this.
I am Gary Woods, Merrimack 23, representing Bowen Dunbarton, and I'm here to introduce House Bill 1038, Naming a Bridge in Londonderry, in Honor of Robert J.
Prouse.
Just for those of you who may not know where that bridge is, it's on 93, just north of exit 4.
That bridge that was there has been called by the locals, as I understand, the Ash Street Bridge.
And it actually is right almost on the line between Londonderry and Derry.
It is in Londonderry.
But it's a conduit between the two.
That bridge was already named the Robert J.
Prowse Bridge.
However, because of the 93 renovation, it was taken down and preserved actually and put up for bid and Keene bought it and will use it as a footbridge where I'm not sure.
I don't think at this point it's up and running, shall we say, but it is going to be used.
The new bridge is obviously functional after the renovation of I-93.
And that brings us to the question, why am I sitting here representing Bowen Dunbarton, sponsoring a bill for something in Londonderry?
Not it'll come together.
It turns out the family lives in Concord, in Bow, and they reached out to the family and they, quote, the department proposes naming the new bridge the Robert J.
Prouse Bridge to continue to honor Robert Prouse if the family is amenable.
At that juncture, they identified to Joyce Prouse, the daughter-in-law of Robert J.
Prouse, that the department can't do that.
That has to go through the legislative process.
And she says, aha, my next-door neighbor is a representative.
I'll talk to him.
That in addition to the fact that I'm a retired orthopedic surgeon and I've taken care of individuals in the family for somewhere between 30 and 40 years.
So besides being my next door neighbor, I've known from the medical area, and thus I was asked to see if I could bring this forward.
The bridge itself currently is not the exact same design, but the department felt that they wanted to at least keep a bridge named for him.
I have a summary, and I'll leave this and you can read it, regarding him.
He was born in Concord, lived from 06 to 1969.
He served in World War II, was an engineer from the start and worked his way up through the department and was key in developing the change in bridge design from riveting to welding.
In that process, he ended up personally designed no fewer than 180 New Hampshire highway bridges and was the administrator overseeing the design of more than 400 bridges.
Again, this was very innovative and got national recognition.
And that placed New Hampshire at the forefront of the application of welded girder technology, which became the dominant technology for the fabrication of steel bridges, steel bridges members in the latter half of the 20th century.
So we have a conquered individual who has gained national recognition, and the department as well as the family would very much like to continue to honor his memory by naming that bridge the Robert J.
Prowse Bridge.
And I'll leave this and this gives a little bit more.
This is from a biography that is in the Department of Transportation and the daughter-in-law, my neighbor, excerpted a few comments from that to help you understand who he was as a person.
I'll take any questions.
Questions from the committee?
Representative Puget.
Yes, thank you.
I just wondered if this had been brought before the Londonderry Town Government for their approval.
Yes, I did, in fact, contact both.
I forgot to mention that.
I contacted both managers and asked if they had any, they would like to provide any input or they had anything that would take precedence as it would be locally if that would be the case and both indicated that they did not, which raises a question that I have for you folks is, is there any other documentation relative to this that I need to bring forward to either verify that or any other documentation that's needed?
Go ahead, continue.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Yes, I think that it's been traditional that we have some kind of written documentation from the municipal.
From each, although it's in Londonderry, you would like one from Derry as well?
I'll answer that.
If it's physically in Londonderry, something from the town of Londonderry will be sufficient.
And the reason we do this is we have run into problems in the past where we have tried to name something unbeknownst to the town, and they were not happy.
Not necessarily disagreeing, but we're not happy that the legislature were just running over their bridges and the rest.
There we go.
That should be addressed to you as chair?
Yes, that would be sufficient.
Thank you for that input.
Other questions?
Seeing none, thank you very much.
I see a member from DOT here.
I do have a question.
You didn't think you were going to get off that easy, did you?
Good morning, Mr.
Chair, members of the committee.
Kathy Mulcahy-Hampson, Senior Hearings Examiner and Legislative Liaison for New Hampshire Department of Transportation.
The previous speaker talked about that the department was in favor of this naming of the bridge, and that there had been a bridge that was already named for him.
Could you walk us through, is it in the same place?
Do we really need to rename something that's been named before, or can we just say it's just a replacement bridge and the name stays the same?
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
The department does not take positions on naming bills, but we do help to facilitate when bills want to be brought forward.
And the family members had contacted the department, and we advised them how to proceed with the process of this legislation.
The prior Ash Street Bridge was removed as part of the I-93 project and it was purchased by the City of Keene and is going to be moved to Keene and made part of a historic trail project.
It was named after Mr.
Prowse because it was a unique design on the bridge that he designed.
So the name stays with the old bridge, and the new bridge would need to be named.
Thank you.
Any questions of the Department from members?
Representative Faulkner.
Thank you.
Any questions of the department from members?
Representative Faulkner.
My understanding is that Keene doesn't like to name its bridges.
Are they getting an indication that they would keep the same name for that bridge?
Thank you for the question.
We haven't had any conversations with the City of Keene on that, Representative Faulkner.
Thank you.
Seeing no other questions, thank you very much for trying to clarify some of this.
I have no other pink cards on House Bill 1038, naming a bridge in Londonderry in honor of Robert J.
Prouse.
Is there anybody who has not testified who wishes to testify?
Anybody who wishes to testify a second time?
Seeing none, public hearing on House Bill 1038 is closed.
I had planned on doing the executive session on this, but it has been the longstanding tradition of this committee that we have something in writing from the town, and I would like to keep with that tradition so we will have to hold off on the executive session.
But before I do, just a quick straw poll.
Is there anybody opposed to this bill?
Seeing no hands, the exec session will be very short once we get that piece of paper.
That being said, our next bill, I thought we'd spend a few minutes on the exec session, but our next bill is not until 10 a.m.
It is House Bill 1456 relative to the Hampton Marine Memorial.
We are on break until 10 a.m.
Thank you.
All right.
I was just going to say, can everyone make sure they speak closely to the mic sue and i are right by the the like thing and so it's very hard to hear that is helpful and that's why there are mics at every station.
As you probably looking at the bill and the next one, I am a co-sponsor of both of them.
And the vice chairman will be running the hearings on both of those bills.
Yes.
Well, we're doing one, one at a time.
The time being 10 o'clock, we will open up House Bill 1456, relative to the Hampton Marine Memorial.
And we will recognize the prime sponsor, Representative Edgar.
Please.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Again, for the record, my name is Mike Edgar.
I'm a representative representing Hampton.
The amendment addresses the change effective date from 60 days after its passage to taking effect upon passage.
so what we have here is we have the bill HB 1456 and also the amendment 2022 0039H you should have a copy of the amendment at your desk.
The Hampton Marine Memorial is a state memorial.
That's why we're dealing with it today.
It's located, for those that don't know about it, it's located in Hampton on Ocean Boulevard, pretty much across from Ashworth by the sea, and that's at basically 295 Ocean Boulevard.
The Hampton Marine Memorial was created in 1957 to provide a place for those buried or lost at sea so they could be recognized.
It depicts a gold star mother laying a wreath upon the sea.
Most of the names on the memorial, those from basically service members and merchant marine service members who were lost at sea during World War II, that's the bulk of the names on the memorial.
In 1990, the eligibility requirements was extended to include those mentioned, Richard Marine members that I just mentioned, and those of the Vietnam conflict.
HB 1456 extends the eligibility period to include Operation Desert Shield, Desert Storm, and the wars on terrorism following the September 11th attack.
Burke Bennett, American Legion Commander, Post 35, is present and will be speaking and provide more details concerning the monument.
I must admit that I do have a personal interest in this.
A neighbor of mine, Jonathan Currier, was lost at sea.
He was a corporal in the United States Marine Corps, and he was lost at sea on August 9, 2018, off the coast of the Philippines.
Please consider the amendment that I mentioned and the Unlion bill.
So I don't think if there are any questions.
Are there any questions for the representative?
Seeing none, thank you.
I would like to call on Berkley Bennett, if I could please.
Please come forward.
Sir, welcome to Public Works, and please introduce yourself.
Well, good morning.
Chairman Graham, I would like to thank you and the members of the committee for the opportunity to speak in favor of HB 1456, which would include recent conflicts and allow additional names to be added to the Hampton Marine Memorial at Hampton Beach.
My name is Berkeley Bennett, and I'm the commander of American Legion Post 35 in Hampton.
As a bit of background, as Representative Edgar mentioned, the idea for a memorial came from Manchester resident William E.
Downs.
His son, Army Captain William D.
Downs, had died aboard ship while returning from the South Pacific in World War II and was buried at sea in May of 1945.
Mr.
Downs attempted to get a grave marker for a token burial plot for his son, but was told at the time that the federal government would not provide grave markers for those who had died at sea.
Frustrated, he approached William Loeb of the Manchester Union leader for help.
And this was the beginning of the creation of a memorial for those from New Hampshire who were lost at sea in all wars.
In 1950, Governor Sherman Adams created the New Hampshire Marine Memorial Commission, and after seven years of study, hard work, and fundraising, the Lady of the Sea Marine Memorial was dedicated on Decoration Day 1957.
The memorial includes the names of 248 men, not only World War II veterans, but also two service members who were killed when the USS Maine exploded in Havana Harbor prior to the Spanish-American War, five veterans of World War I who died when their ships were sunk en route to France, and one sailor who was lost when the destroyer USS Reuben James was sunk by a German U-boat just prior to America's entrance into World War II.
In 1990, legislation was adopted to include Vietnam War veterans and World War II Merchant Mariners on the memorial.
On Memorial Day 1993, the memorial was rededicated, adding 42 names to the honor roll, including 24 Merchant Mariners.
The memorial presently has 290 names, but the design allows for over 400.
The purpose of this bill is to seek the addition of more recent New Hampshire service members who were lost at sea while serving in Operation Desert Shield, Desert Storm, and the Global War on Terrorism.
One such member, Hampton native Marine Corporal Jonathan Currier, was believed to have fallen overboard while deployed aboard the amphibious assault ship USS Essex while sailing off the coast of the Philippines in August of 2018.
He was declared lost at sea.
His body never recovered.
Another service member, Marine Captain Gary Dillon of Concord, would also be eligible for inclusion if this bill was passed.
Captain Dillon, a Marine aviator, was killed in a helicopter mid-air collision while conducting night vision goggle training in the Arabian Sea.
This happened just before the onset of hostilities and desert storm.
His body was also never recovered.
When I spoke to the Division of Parks and Recreation about how to go about adding names to the memorial, I was told the criteria is set through the legislature, and that's when I reached out to Representative Edgar for help.
His efforts have led to the bill that is before this committee.
The Marine Memorial doesn't exist just to memorialize those lost in World War I or World War II.
It needs to continue as a living monument to honor those lost at sea defending our country today.
Passing this bill would allow Jonathan and Gary's names to be added to the stone.
It would allow the Lady of the Sea Memorial to provide solace to the Courier family, where Jonathan played on the beach beneath her gaze as a child.
With its location at the edge of the shore, overlooking the vast ocean that is the final resting place of so many of our heroes, an updated memorial would allow tens of thousands of people who visit Hampton Beach the opportunity to pause and reflect on the continuing cost of our freedom.
I thank you for the opportunity to address you this morning, and I strongly urge you to support this bill.
Thank you.
Thank you, Ms.
Bennett, for your service and all the good folks at Post 35.
Are there questions for Mr.
Bennett?
Yes.
Yes, thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
I just wondered if this had been, as far as the inscription of the names and so forth, that that's going to be done through the Division of Parks and Recreation and the Department of Natural and Cultural Resources.
Are they on board with this?
or have they been solicited for providing the funds for doing this?
Yes, sir.
As the previous bill mentioned, it is the responsibility of DNCR to fund the engraving of the names of the memorial.
and I have reached out to the department, and they are aware, and they have in fact reiterated that it is their responsibility to engrave the names.
Thank you, Representative.
Are there any other questions?
Seeing none, thank you.
Thank you.
We'll now recognize Gail Wallach.
Would you please come forward and welcome to Public Works.
Good morning, Mr.
Chairman, members of the committee.
My name is Gail Wallach and I am the Deputy Director of the Department of Natural and Cultural Resources Division of Parks and Recreation.
I have brought copies of what I'm about to read for our testimony for you.
Please accept this testimony on behalf of the Department of Natural and Cultural Resources Division of Parks and Recreation regarding HB 1456 relative to the Hampton Marine Memorial.
The Division supports this bill to honor the veterans by adding the names of those lost at sea to the Marine Memorial from recent military conflicts and the September 11th, 2001 attack.
We have conducted additional research since our submission of the fiscal note.
The Marine Memorial has room to add up to 233 names.
As of this writing, the estimated cost to add names to the memorial is $9 per letter or an average of $180 per name at 20 characters with a $140 one-time setup fee.
Using this information, approximately 50 to 55 names could be added for the cost of $10,000 as proposed in the fiscal note.
As required by law, costs would be paid from existing departmental appropriations.
There is currently approximately a two-year wait for new engraving work, but that time could be used to allow the appropriate veterans organizations to provide us with the names of veterans that need to be added to the Marine Memorial.
We thank you for the opportunity to provide testimony on this bill and are happy to answer any questions.
Thank you, Deputy Director.
Other questions?
Seeing none, thank you for your testimony.
If we could just trouble you to pass a copy of your testimony on.
Thank you.
To the clerk.
The clerk.
Is there anyone here, anyone else that wishes to testify on House Bill 1456?
Seeing none, we will call the public hearing to a close at 10-12.
Thank you, Mark.
I will now open the executive session on House Bill 1436, an act relative to the Hampton Marine Memorial.
You can come back to your chairs.
Representative Edgar moves Amendment 2022-039H.
Is there a second?
Second.
Mr.
Chairman, I will second that motion.
Representative Edgar moved and Representative Cloutier seconded the approval of Amendment 2022-0039H.
Is there any discussion on the amendment?
Seeing none, all those in favor of the adoption of the amendment signify by saying aye.
Opposed nay.
The ayes have it, unless my hearing is gone, unanimously.
I would look to Representative Edgar for a motion of ought to pass as amended on House Bill 1456FN.
Yes, sir, I make that motion motion Chairman.
Representative Edgar moves out to pass as amended on House Bill 1456.
Is there a second?
Representative McConkie seconded the motion.
Discussion on the motion of ought to pass as amended.
See none.
Oh, Representative Query.
Yeah, I just wanted to say I think this is a no-brainer.
I would just ask that we not put it on consent calendar so that we can take the appropriate moment to recognize the people that we've lost at sea on the day of when we hear this in session.
Thank you.
You're one step ahead of me.
I was going to ask about consent after we had passed the motion of ought to pass as amended.
However, seeing no further discussion, the clerk will call the roll.
Senator McConkie.
Aye.
Senator Sauer.
Senator Jaggi.
Yes.
I would ask that you remember to press the little red button so that your votes are going out live to those who are watching the testimony that is being live streamed.
Just a reminder.
Thank you.
We'll continue from where you were.
Representative Thompson.
Aye.
Thank you.
We'll continue from where you were.
Yes.
Representative Abbott?
Representative Faulkner?
Yes.
Representative Newman?
Representative Eaton?
Aye.
And Mr.
Chairman?
Yes.
The vote is 15 to—oh.
You skipped two people.
Oh.
Yes.
The vote is 15 to 0.
You skipped two people.
I'm sorry, there are people on the back.
Representative Query.
Aye.
Yes.
The vote is 17 to 0.
The motion of ought to pass as amended is adopted.
And at the request of representative query, it will go on to the regular calendar.
Again, I didn't time this right.
We have about 10 minutes until our next bill, which is House Bill 1553 relative to roadside memorials.
Once again, I am a co-sponsor and the vice chair will be conducting the hearing on that bill.
We will reconvene at 10.30.
Thank you.
We will start the hearing in two minutes.
If anyone else wishes to speak, please fill out a pink card and pass it forward to the clerk, please.
Thank you.
What Bradley is handing out right now is an amendment to the bill that we will hear next, not this bill.
So please just set it aside so we can concentrate on what's in front of us.
And we will discuss that amendment at the appropriate time.
Thank you.
prime sponsor representative eaton please good morning mr chairman and members my name is Daniel Eaton representing Cheshire district 3 I guess everything that's old is new again this is not the first time the committee has seen this bill and the basis for the bill is that we have in the last dozen years or, seen a rapid increase of roadside memorials being dropped all over the state.
For those of you that don't know what a roadside memorial is, it is usually placed on the side of the road when there has been a fatal accident and someone wants to memorialize the loss at that location.
in prior years, back during my tenure as a police chief on a stretch of highway that had probably more than its fair share of fatals, it wasn't abnormal to see some sort of memorial go up within a week or two after the loss of life, and it would stay for 30 or 60 days and disappear again.
Now the tendency is to not just place a memorial, bearing in mind that more often than not, the location of these memorials is already an unsafe location.
So any activity there is, one, a distraction to ongoing drivers.
Two, activity by family members at that location creates an obstruction.
They are going back and putting up plastic flowers spring or fall.
The new magic trick is to put battery-operated lights, so you're distracted both day and night.
A loss of life is a tragedy for anyone under any circumstance, but the fact is the overwhelming majority of people have a grave or an urn or somewhere to have their private moments for dealing with a memorial of an individual lost.
To place it on a public highway makes it a public event.
It is sometimes, sadly, more about the person left behind than the person that has been lost and is not a good public service.
Add to that that the Department of Transportation is required to maintain the sides of the roads year-round.
Frequently, these set up an obstruction, making it very difficult, if not impossible, for doing their jobs properly, adequately, and more importantly, safely.
For that and many other reasons, I'd be happy to bring up, but would like to keep this timely.
I'll conclude and be more than happy to answer any questions.
Thank you, Representative.
Are there questions for Representative Eaton?
Seeing none, thank you for your testimony.
Appreciate getting let off the hook.
We try and move quick.
The chair will recognize David Rodri from Department of Transportation.
David, welcome back.
It's nice to see you again.
Good morning.
Thank you, Representative.
Nice to see you and nice to see everybody from the committee today.
Thank you for having me.
For the record, my name is David Rodriguez, Director of Operations for the Department of Transportation.
I would like to start by reinforcing all of the points that the sponsor made as he introduced the bill.
The department would concur that that is an accurate analysis.
I want to go on to explain our current practice.
The department currently removes memorials that are a hazard immediately.
We remove memorials that interfere with maintenance or mowing when the operations occur.
And memorials that are set back away from the road or are not an immediate hazard to the motorist often stay in the right of way for some time.
Removal of roadside memorials is an emotionally charged issue and it's for that reason that the department appreciates the legislature taking up this issue and letting us know what the will of the people is, and we will follow that will of the people.
And I'd be happy to take any questions.
Thank you.
Are there questions for Mr.
Rodriguez for the department?
Seeing none.
Thank you, sir.
Oh, I apologize.
Representative Newman?
Yes.
Thank you sir.
I apologize.
Representative Newman.
Yes.
I have to keep holding this one.
Okay.
Thank you.
My question is on the, in section two on the back side here, when the legislation talks about if not removed pursuant to the RSA, the department shall remove and dispose after 90 days, commencing from the date of the event being memorialized.
How do you keep track of when 90 days is?
So currently we do not keep track.
The law would require us to keep some sort of track of that.
We believe the bill as written is permissive.
It directs us after 90 days to remove it.
So we don't read that to be on the 91st day, but we do read that to be within a reasonable amount of time after 90 days.
So we would have to track that to an extent.
But because we believe the bill is permissive, we think that'll be a manageable thing for us to do.
Thank you.
Any further questions?
Seeing none.
Thank you.
Is there anyone else present that would wish to testify on House Bill 1553-FN?
Seeing none, we will close this hearing.
Thank you, Representative McConkie.
I will now open the Executive Session on House Bill 1553, an act relative to roadside memorials.
What is the will of the Committee?
Representative Eaton.
Mr.
Chairman, I would defer to Representative Cloutier, please.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
I move ought to pass on House Bill 1553.
Representative Cloutier moves House Bill 1553 ought to pass.
Is there a second?
Representative Eaton seconds the motion.
Discussion on the bill and the recommendation of ought to pass.
Representative Thomas.
Okay, so can everybody hear me?
All right.
I believe this is an important bill.
This is the third time we've had this bill.
I think it was Representative Eaton first introduced it, I believe, in 2018.
He again introduced it 2020.
The Senate, for some reason, in 2018 didn't want to go along with it.
And then in 2020, when I was chair, because it was passed by our committee in the full House, but then COVID hit and there were so many other, Senate had other priorities.
They thought this was not a priority, so they let it die.
I think it's time that we pass this bill again and send it to the Senate and try to, you know, really persuade the Senate that this is a very important public safety issue for the DOT.
And IT.
and I think it even affects our local highway departments as well and I think it's time to get it done I think it's common sense I know there are emotional issues involved but I think this is a reasonable bill that is permissive and has been written very carefully so I would urge this off you all to support the motion about to pass.
Thank you.
Representative Thompson.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
I'd just like to go on the record as saying I think that the 90-day allowance to remove the memorial, and in light of what Mr.
Rodriguez said, the department, you know, endeavors to make it 90 days, but sometimes it takes longer.
My personal feeling from watching one of the most horrific accidents we had up in the North country this year, or two years ago, watching what happened with the memorial that was placed there on the side of the road immediately after.
It's not 90 days or 120 days out.
It's the first 30 days that these people tend to congregate on these memorials, and I think that I personally would like to see a 30-day removal.
I think beyond that, people can go to the grave and mourn there.
It may not be a popular decision, but that's my opinion.
Thank you.
Any further representative, Faulkner?
I would agree with that, but I also would like to add that there are, they were not restricting memorials that might be on private property, and although memorials along Route 2 there, people put their own memorials on their private property, so that wouldn't be affected if people want to do that that would continue so i think the fact i think that we've provided as much of a you know access to the public as is needed even with 30 days Representative Query.
I have a little bit of a concern about some of the costs that might pop up over time, but I guess we'll see if that as it comes.
It won't stop me, but I do feel like there will probably be a little bit of a clerical cost just to track all this information, but then also the disposal of these memorials might start costing now that they're being collected quicker.
And then potentially, while things are still in good condition within that 90-day time frame, people who left those memorials may want to try and collect what is left over from them.
So I do think that there could be some storage costs and disposal costs that might pop up, but it won't stop me from voting in favor of this.
Thank you.
Any further discussion?
Seeing none.
The clerk will call the roll.
All right.
Representative McConkie.
Aye.
Representative Summerow.
Representative Fidolfi.
Aye.
Representative Blasek.
Representative Fidolfi.
Aye.
Representative Blasek.
Representative Gagne.
Aye.
Representative Thompson.
Representative Cloutier.
Yes.
Representative Edgar.
Aye.
Representative Tlerski.
Representative Cloutier.
Aye.
Representative Tlerski.
Representative Tludier.
Yes.
Representative Edgar.
Aye.
Representative Klarski.
Yes.
Clerk votes yes.
Representative Abbott.
Yes.
Representative Faulkner.
Representative Newman.
Yes.
Representative Eaton.
Aye.
Representative Query.
Representative Bunker.
Thank you.
Representative Query?
Aye.
Representative Bunker?
Yes.
Mr.
Chairman?
Yes.
The vote being 17 to 0, the motion of ought to pass is adopted.
Is there any objection to the consent calendar?
Seeing none, it will go on to the consent calendar.
I'll close the executive session on House Bill 1553.
Once again, I misjudged the time, but if I did these things in 15-minute increments, we'd be running over.
You just don't know.
We have 15 minutes until our next hearing, which is House Bill 1572 relative to funds credited to the harbor dredging peer maintenance and make an appropriation for dredging of the harbors.
I will ask everybody to be back at 11.
Thank you very much.
I think too many people have their buttons pressed when it goes green.
So I think everyone just needs to make sure they turn off after they speak Thank you.
Thank you.
The time being 11 a.m., I would call to order the public hearing on House Bill 1572-FN-A, an act relative to funds credited to the Harbor Dredging and Peer Maintenance Fund, and making appropriations for dredging of Rye Harbor and Seabrook-Hampton Harbor.
The sponsors not being here, I would recognize Representative Query to introduce the bill to the committee.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
In the absence of the sponsors and co-sponsors, I'm gonna be introducing HB 1572 FNA.
Thank you, and there will be no questions.
He's doing this as a courtesy to the committee.
Nobody is here to testify.
We have an amendment that was handed out.
The amendment is non-germane to the bill as introduced.
We will not be discussing that amendment.
Any questions or comments about that seeing none and not knowing what the committee wants to do I will close the public hearing on House Bill 1572 FNA and I will open the executive session on House Bill 1572 FNA.
Well, wait a minute.
Let me reopen the hearing.
Does anybody need to hear, or does the ports and harbor need to say anything about the original bill?
Anybody have any questions of them?
Okay.
We'll roll back into executive session.
I will say that I talked to Ms.
Marconi about what the bill did.
He does not need anything from us to change anything, add any money, or anything else for dredging and harbor maintenance.
And for some of us, we hear it on a regular basis in some of the statutory committees.
And so I was kind of confused when I first saw the bill anyways on what he needed.
That being said, we are in executive session on House Bill 1572 as introduced.
What is the pleasure of the committee?
Mr.
Chairman, I would like to move ITL.
Representative Edgar moves ITL on House Bill 1572 as introduced, seconded by Representative Abbott is there any discussion Representative Query I have a parliamentary question and we can answer it after the executive session it's just about like who can introduce amendments the committee.
The sponsors have a lot of leeway on bringing clarifying amendments to their bills.
It is something that most chairmen will ask the sponsors to do if they want to have something changed, that they do the amendment and bring it forward.
The committee doesn't have to accept any amendment brought in by anybody to include a member of the committee, but it would be up to the members of the committee for somebody to move approval of an amendment, second it, and then we would have the normal procedure, and then it becomes a committee amendment.
But if you have a bill in front of another committee that you need to have something changed in because it didn't get printed quite right or whatever, you should, as the sponsor, make the amendment to cut down on the work of the committee because they might just say, we're not going to bother to do your work.
So that's kind of where that whole issue is.
Thank you.
Seeing no further discussion, the clerk will call the roll on inexpedient to legislative House Bill 1572.
Okay.
Representative McConkie.
Aye.
Representative Somerle.
Representative Fidelphi.
Aye.
Representative Blasek.
Representative Gagney.
Yes.
Thompson Yes.
Representative Cloutier Yes.
Representative Edgar Aye.
Representative Tlurski Yes.
Clerk votes yes.
Representative Abbott Yes.
Representative Faulkner Yes.
Representative Newman Yes.
Yes.
Representative Abbott.
Representative Faulkner.
Yes.
Representative Newman.
Representative Eaton.
Yes.
Representative Query.
Representative Bunker.
Yes.
And Mr.
Chairman.
Yes.
The vote on the inexpedient to legislate motion is 17 to 0.
The vote on the inexpedient to legislate motion is 17 to 0 and is adopted.
Is there any objection to consent calendar?
It will come off, I'm sure, but let's put it there to start.
Seeing none, it will go under the consent calendar, and I hereby close the executive session on House Bill 1572.
Thank you for coming, Gino.
Appreciate it.
Okay.
We have – I really did expect that one to last longer.
Our next hearing is at 1.15 on relative agency reporting.
I know that – you want to do the caucus?
At this time?
Yeah.
Would the Republicans would like to caucus, and we will caucus in this room.
Room 300.
Oh, I'm sorry, room 300 as soon as we adjourn from here.
Republican caucus, room 300.
Thank you.
Thank you all for some quick work this morning.
And I will see everybody back here at 115.
And we'll see where we go from there.
Thank you.
Anyone who is going to be testifying on House Bill 1217, please fill out a pink card and make sure it gets to the front.
The time being 1.15, I would call the public hearing on House Bill 1217 relative to agency reporting of state-owned property to order and would recognize Representative Trottier, the prime sponsor.
Good afternoon, members and Mr.
Chair.
I'd like to thank you for your...
Good afternoon, members and Mr.
Chair.
I'd like to thank you for your time and consideration on House Bill 1217 FM.
It has been brought to my attention that the state does not have a centralized database to keep track of all state-owned property that is abandoned or vacant.
So this is abandoned or vacant.
So this bill would, it's been brought to my attention that each individual agency, it could be DOT, Department of Safety, and so on, have certain properties under their control.
So with this bill, my goal is to require each state agency that has property under their control to report that to the administrative services who should keep a centralized database whereby the public has a knowledge and biannually what I would like to see is that the administrative services files a report on each piece of property that is either vacant or abandoned explaining if the property could be sold transferred to the community where it is located so it can be put back on the tax base.
I know in the town that I represent and where I live in the town of Belmont we currently have a state property up there that people have interested in purchasing.
It was under the Department of Safety.
Marine Patrol was there until their new facility was built, and I'm just being told it's being used to store some equipment.
So that is my goal with this bill.
If there's some state properties that we have no intentions of using, developing, expanding, I would like to see if there's any way of unloading that from the state by sales, transfer to the communities, and get it back on the tax map to help these communities that are struggling to get more taxes brought in.
Thank you.
Any questions from the committee to the representative?
I see none.
I do have one.
Why do you think that the current RSA 439 E reporting requirements of property owned by state agencies does not fit the same bill and this would be redundant to that?
Thank you.
Any further questions from the committee?
Representative Thompson.
Don't we have, and I'll address this to you, Representative, but I'm not sure you'll know.
Doesn't surplus property have a list of those properties?
Representative, we will be hearing from administrative services in just a minute.
I think that question is probably more appropriate to them or the other agencies that are here to speak.
Seeing none, thank you.
Next I'd like to call Mr.
Jared Nyland, Department of Administrative Services, who is in opposition to the bill.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair and, sorry, representatives.
Department of Administrative Services is opposed to the proposed legislation.
Essentially the concern of the department is the resting, the bill rests on two terms, vacant and abandoned, which are not defined in the statute and don't have a consistent meaning in the real estate industry.
We would point the committee or the sponsor to Senate Bill 359, which was introduced last week, which is a similar type of bill.
It has some issues of its own, but we think it provides a more workable framework for mandating state agencies to publicly identify surplus real property assets.
I have a brief summary written testimony here to offer if you'd like to circulate that.
Any questions?
Questions of the committee?
I do have one.
And It is my understanding that there is an electronic version of the inventory of state property that is currently required to be maintained by the department that is accessible to the public electronically.
Is that not true?
There we go.
That is correct.
Yes, the department maintains, as far as I know, the only statewide inventory of state real property.
It's in database form.
It is electronically accessible online.
It does not include designations of whether property is abandoned or vacant.
Thank you.
Representative Faulkner.
Is there a consistent, I think you hinted that there wasn't a consistent process by which an agency would determine property surplus.
Surplus is the term we really want to look at, isn't it?
Is there a consistent process across the different agencies, or does each agency develop its own process?
Thank you.
So as I understand the question, you're asking if each agency has its own process for determining whether a property is surplus.
I believe that's true to the extent that there is a process.
It is in the discretion of each agency, and it's in the context of the proposed disposal of surplus real estate.
And that's usually, that's almost always the context in which it is made.
So most agencies don't review their inventory and say, okay, this one's surplus, this one's not.
That's not a normal occurrence.
That usually only happens when a property has been identified as one that they are looking to dispose of.
Thank you.
Representative Thompson.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
I guess that raises a question.
Why aren't they already identified as to whether they're abandoned?
I mean, it seems like that's – it just doesn't make a lot of sense to me that you only look at a particular property that you want to get rid of.
Shouldn't you look at all of them and decide which ones need to be disposed of?
I can think of a half a dozen right off the top of my head around the state.
I mean, that could be the case.
I don't believe that's currently a policy that we follow in general.
But if the legislature decides to make that a policy that we should follow, then we could do that.
Okay.
Thank you.
Representative Eaton.
I served on a committee about 10 years ago that was charged with disposing of so-called abandoned properties.
Would you believe that we found going through the process of what we thought were abandoned properties were actually properties that had use years down the road that we weren't readily seeing that moment in front of us.
And a legislative mandate may cause greater expense for the state over a course of time than doing what that committee did at the time, which was find readily disposable properties.
And I think that the last couple questions have been trying to get an answer that is not within the purview of one department, that each department has some purview over that.
And we do have RSAs that deal with the disposal of property.
And if we want to change those, anybody can file a bill next term to do that.
But I think we're asking the representative, DAS, to make generalities about property that belonged to other agencies and how they handle that.
Any other questions?
Representative Cloutier.
Thank you.
I'm wondering, Mr.
Nyland, and this is some questions about the bill's fiscal note, and I don't know if you can answer them, and I noticed that it was written on October 28th of last year, and then there's a methodology, and this is the second paragraph, and going down, the Department of Administrative Services states they do not currently collect the information required by the bill, nor do they have direct access to the information for state real property managed by other state agencies.
Therefore, in order to collect and maintain the property information, there would be an indeterminable increase on various state expenditures.
It goes on to state that as of the date of October 28th, they were unable to determine the additional staff hours or additional staff across different agencies that would be needed to meet the required obligations in the bill.
By any chance, I don't know if you can answer this question, have you done any more research for this fiscal note and have an updated fiscal note or could get this committee more information?
Or does it stand what was written on October 28th of last year?
You mean as far as the fiscal?
Yeah, you're right.
As far as an indeterminable, if we pass this bill as written, it might be an indeterminable increase to the state budget for various state agencies.
Okay.
I have no further information to offer on that at this time.
I believe that the use of the primary terms vacant and abandoned is just, it's very difficult, you know, with no definitions in the bill, it's very difficult to determine what that means or what kind of analysis that's going to involve by individual state agencies.
Okay, so in other words, follow up, Mr.
Chairman, the fiscal note is written right now, has not been changed or updated, right?
As far as I know.
Okay, all right, great.
Thank you.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Thank you.
Any further questions?
Seeing none, thank you very much.
Thank you.
Any further questions?
Seeing none, thank you very much.
Next, I'd like to call Patrick Hackley, Division of Forests and Lands, who says he has written testimony but does not indicate whether he supports or opposes the bill.
And hopefully it won't take 10 minutes.
and members of the committee for the record my name is Patrick Hackley.
I'm the new face of the Division of Forests and Lands, the director for that agency.
And we don't have a formal position.
We just have some input to provide as you consider this bill.
So our division is under the Department of Natural and Cultural Resources.
The Division of Forests and Lands is we're the agency in the execution of all matters pertaining to forestry of state lands within the jurisdiction of the state.
Our agency manages 218 state reservations, and these are designated as either state forests, parks, natural areas, or historic sites.
And that totals approximately 170,000 acres from Pittsburgh to Nashua and everywhere in between.
The bill as proposed should provide a definition of the terms.
These are just our, this is our constructive input.
And as the speaker before me mentioned, the terms vacant and abandoned imply a property with no value or particular use to the public state reservations include both developed state parks and undeveloped state forests that we actively manage or simply hold to provide a host of public benefits the following New Hampshire statute provides greater detail as follows this is under RSA chapter 227 H1.
It is hereby recognized and declared that the state-owned reservations contribute to the conservation of natural resources and a distinctive quality of life in the state.
The public welfare of the state is served by the prudent acquisition and management of reservations to provide forest benefits for the purposes of demonstrating sound forestry, protecting habitat for plants, animals, and other organisms, conserving forested watersheds, preserving areas of rare or exemplary natural beauty and ecological value, and providing for perpetual public use and access.
So these forest benefits are further defined in RSA 227 G2.
Forest benefits include but are not limited to forest products, a viable forest based economy, recreation opportunities, scenic values, healthful surroundings, climate mitigation, clean water, and biologically diverse populations of plants and animals.
So we recommend that the bill, at the very least, define the terms vacant and abandoned to ensure that these terms are not broadly defined without considering each state agency's purpose and mission for holding and managing that property.
So that's the gist of my formal comments.
I have copies here I can share with the committee.
I'm happy to take any questions that you may have.
Thank you.
Questions from the committee?
Seeing none, thank you.
And I'd like to call Steve Lebronte from New Hampshire Department of Transportation, who again neither supports nor opposes the bill.
Turn the mic on.
Thank you.
As you just said, my name is Steve Labonte.
I am the administrator of the Bureau of Right-of-Way with the New Hampshire Department of Transportation.
A little background on the Bureau is that it's best described as the real estate agency of the department.
We survey the property that we'll need for upcoming projects.
We'll appraise the property that we need.
We acquire the property, manage the property, and ultimately dispose of the property when it becomes surplus.
The bill as it's written, or let me back up for a minute, the New Hampshire Department of Transportation owns 724 properties that lie outside of our active right-of-way.
Out of those, we've broken those properties down into three groups.
Fifty-nine are potentially marketable to the general public in that they're large enough to either develop or they may have already been developed and someone from the general public could come in, purchase it, and put it to use.
Another 185 are marketable, but to a narrow market, meaning that it might be too small to develop, but still adds some value to an abutter, or it could be landlocked, so there's no access.
So they're marketable, but typically those are marketable to abutters.
480 are not marketable, meaning that they're these tiny slivers of land that are scattered, you know, left over when roads were altered and projects in the past.
So this bill would create a large burden on the department, department and I don't know that we could do this by any of the – we could meet that deadline.
And I will tell you that right now the public has no problem contacting us to buy property.
I get requests to dispose of property weekly.
Typically how that works is a member of the public will contact me, send in a request, they'll give us a location map, and then what we do is we start our departmental review.
And that departmental review will then take a look at the property.
We have engineers from our Bureau of Highway Design as well as our Bureau of Highway Maintenance look at it.
Also, our Bureau of Environment will look at the property, and they'll determine whether this is actually surplus to the departmental operational needs.
so we have a system in place I think this bill and I would point out the language used whether it's vacant or abandoned I would say none of the department's properties are abandoned and although a large amount might be vacant it it doesn't mean it's surplus to the department's needs.
So I'm happy to take any questions that the committee may have.
Thank you.
Representative Faulkner.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Looking at it from the point of view, we mentioned somebody that might be interested in acquiring one of these properties.
Could they go to their town's tax maps and identify properties that are owned by the state or by the department?
Is that typically how that gets started?
Yes, they could.
That's quite often how they do it.
Further questions?
Seeing none, thank you.
I have no further pink cards on this bill.
Does anybody who has testified one time wish to speak again?
Anybody who has not testified wishing to testify, please indicate now.
Seeing none, I will close the hearing on House Bill 1217.
to open the executive session on House Bill 1217, FN, at this time, is there any general discussion from members of the committee on the bill?
Seeing none, what is the pleasure of the committee, Representative McConkie?
Thank you, Chairman Graham.
I would offer ITL on House Bill 1217FN.
Second.
Representative McConkie has moved in a meeting to legislate, seconded by Representative Eaton.
I will say a couple of things right now.
I was one of the sponsors of what became RSA 39E when we were trying to sell property to make the state solvent at one point because there was not a database anywhere that you could go to and do that.
I have also sat for several terms on long-range planning and utilization, which is a statutory committee that deals with the sale and use of state property.
as uh miss lebronte said, there doesn't seem to be a problem with the public knowing what property is what and coming in and asking us to sell it to them.
And if it's declared surplus by agencies, there is a process under RSA 440 for them to go through because every other agency then has an opportunity to weigh in, as do local communities.
It's not just offered up to sale.
I think that I agree with the ITL motion on this.
I think that if it becomes a problem of what is vacant or abandoned, then we could probably take care of that in rules under RSA 439E, which deals with the database that DAS has to maintain every two years, and it's updated.
So that's where I am.
Any further discussion?
Seeing none, the clerk will call the roll.
Representative McConkie.
Aye.
Representative Somero.
Representative Chlursky.
Aye.
Representative Cloutier.
Representative Edgar.
Aye.
Representative Talurski.
Clerk votes yes.
Representative Abbott.
Yes.
Representative Faulkner.
Representative Newman.
Yes.
Representative Eaton.
Representative Peterson.
Yes.
Representative Query.
Representative Quon Yes Representative Peterson Yes Representative Query Yes Representative Bunker Yes And Mr.
Chairman Yes The vote is 19-0 on the motion of inexpedient to legislate.
Is there any objection to the consent calendar?
Seeing none, it will go on the consent calendar.
Got closer this time.
The next area is at 1.45.
We have about five minutes before that happens.
Thank you.
five minutes before that happens.
Anyone who would like to testify on HB 1211, please fill out a PIN card and bring it up.
Thank you.
All right.
The time being, 1.45, I'd like to call the hearing on House Bill 1211-FN, an act requiring the installation of electronic tolling to order and recognize the prime sponsor, Representative Horrigan.
If you could make sure that's on.
thank you very much Mr.
Chair my name is Representative Timothy Horgan from Stratford County District 6 the Towns of Durham Thank you very much, Mr.
Chair.
My name is Representative Timothy Horrigan from Stratford County District 6, the towns of Durham and Madbury, which is actually also just off of exit 6 off the Spalding Turnpike.
And so HB 1211FN, speech process, which is well underway, which is removal of toll booths from the New Hampshire Turnpike system that's actually the more main input to it impetus for more than also establishment of all electronic tolling which you know it's taken about 35 years or more for toll booth transponders become ubiquitous enough so we know no longer need to do a cash cash toll booths you know the few people don't the transponders, we usually either take a picture of their license plate, you know, all this, or we just write it off.
There's a certain percentage of people who get away with not paying.
And, of course, famously right now the infamous Merrimack toll booths are being torn down.
I mean, that's a somewhat special case because we're also eliminating the tolls, which unfortunately, elsewhere, the toll is still going to be in place.
They're replaced with overhead gantries using E-ZPass supplemented by license plate readers like they have in most neighboring states.
I've made travel trips in New York, New York State, and I didn't go as far as Buffalo, but I could drive all the way from my home to Buffalo, and the only toll booth I'd see with over 600 miles of tolls, which is like some god-awful, with a very large amount of toll taken on my easy pass would be at Hampton, for example.
And so they're relatively rapidly disappearing from our nation-state highways.
I say relatively because, of course, as you all know, highways are built to last for many decades, even centuries, and they change rather slowly.
So Massachusetts took all its tollbooths off the Mass Pike and their tunnels and bridges.
And the tunnels and bridges, about years ago, the last toll booth on the 506-mile New York State Thruway was torn down last summer on August 31, 2021.
I looked it up on the web and saw the press release from the governor's office about it.
Maine is tearing down the York Toll Plaza this summer, although Maine's turnpike's other toll booths will remain in place for a while.
So here in New Hampshire, and they haven't quite been torn down, but my understanding is that Dover and Rochester toll plazas are about to be demolished.
And I'll certainly know if the Dover one is coming down because I drive with inside of it.
I drive through it occasionally, and I'm with inside of it with a lot of frequency because the exit 6 is just downstream.
It's just south of where the existing toll plaza is.
I know it's a project to convert the Bedford toll plaza to Easy Pass, which is starting I think in a year or two.
I think it's scheduled for 2022.
They're all in the 10-year highway plan there's nothing about the hampton or hook set tolls as of yet and unfortunately in the case of hook set they uh just about 10 years ago put in the open road tolling they did the same in hampton so that means uh you know that that means those are newer facilities so it may take a while to uh make it will take a while before you then want to upgrade them to the next level and change all electronic tolling and tear down the toll plazas.
But the reason why – so in my opinion, the existing toll plazas, they're much more expensive to maintain and operate than the overhead gantries, and they're also very dangerous.
I've seen – studies I've seen, so about twice as many accidents happen in the vicinity of toll plazas than in just a regular stretch of a divided highway.
The toll plaza is a large fixed object built across the highway, and every so often someone hit it at full speed with tragic results.
we saw a couple of people a couple of people were killed hitting the Bedford Toll Plaza in December.
And then there's a tragic incident down in New Jersey where two brothers from the Manchester area and their sister were killed on the Atlantic City Expressway in New Jersey because they hit a Toll Plaza while on their Christmas visiting relatives for Christmas.
Those types of accidents wouldn't happen if they weren't there to hit.
The plazas also cause a large number of minor accidents just because drivers have to slow down reading, often confusing, signs and they're weaving from lane to lane to try to figure out what booth to drive through.
Of course, that's probably less of a problem now that every booth except Easy-ZPass, but expensive there now, like there'll be some cash-only booths and some E-ZPass booths, so like, you know, the drivers, you know, they start weaving around and bumping into each other and sometimes even backing up if they think they're going through the wrong booth so so the deadline is pretty far in the future although well it'll be here eventually july 1st 2035 for the removal of all remaining toll booths and that sounds like a long time but now it's 13 years and i've um only been a state rep for 14 years and um so i guess it maybe it's not that long a time but it's three years beyond the date of the current 2023 32 10 year highway plan which is embodied in HB 2022 which hopefully hopefully will go more smoothly than last time and just like we did two years ago and every two years before we'll pass it so it's three years beyond the upcoming 10 year highway plan and, and the fiscal note has an immediate, mentions $235,000 for a feasibility and location study, which would happen during fiscal year 2024.
So I think that would be money well spent.
It would probably help resolve a bunch of issues other than just the narrow ones of wind and whether to tear down the toll plazas and where to put the, and of course where to put the gantries that would replace the two plazas in Hampton and the Hookset Plaza and any other plazas I may have forgotten.
So that's my bill.
It looks rather far in the future, but the future will come here eventually.
And so I'd be happy to take any questions.
Thank you, Representative Cludear.
Sure.
well've got the 10-year highway plan, which appears to have two Toll Plaza-related projects.
It has the Bedford Merrimack project.
I couldn't find anything about the hook set or Hampton Toll booth, but I figured that would give Gassett and this committee and all the other entities involved another couple of years to decide what to do about those locations.
And hopefully they would be – I mean, you could amend this highway plan if you're feeling really courageous, but probably be more realistic to put it in HB 2024, HB 2026, when the time comes along.
But that's – and I just figured that would give everybody a few more years to look down and probably just speed it up.
From what I understand, in addition to what's in the 10-year highway plan, of course, there's a lot of other projects that they've been thinking about, maybe even have some plans for, but given plans.
So that's a.
I just figure that gives you another budget, gives people like at least another legislative cycle to finish it and gives about like, you know, actually like about six or seven more biennia to work out all the fine details.
And if it's not realistic, you can always extend that deadline.
if any of us will probably I see probably some of us will still be here in 2035 when when this deadline comes but I wish I had a better answer than that but that's any further questions from members of the committee seeing none thank you.
I now recognize Mr.
John Corcoran.
Did I say that right?
From New Hampshire Department of Transportation, Turnpike.
Peace.
Good afternoon, Chairman Graham and the rest of the committee.
We are here, the DOT is, my name is John Corcoran, I'm sorry, I'm from the Bureau of Turnpike, I'm an administrator.
And the DOT has no position on this bill.
First, I'd like to explain to you, as Representative Horgan explained to you also, the status of our AET.
Right now we are going AET which is all electronic tolling at night from 10 p.m.
to 6 p.m.
in all our plazas.
Dover Rochester plaza will be AET in fall of this year and then the Bedford plaza will be in 2024.
So everybody knows AET is a cashless tolling, no toll attendance.
We also have a lot of acronyms in tolling and we have ORT which is open road tolling which is high speed tolling in the middle of the plaza and the cash to the right.
And then we have our traditional plaza which is cash and easy pass option.
The department has outlined several several steps in implementation of the AT for 2035 in our fiscal note some of the major steps is beginning is having a feasibility study taming the civil design consultant the design effort for the civil work and then the construction for all this and right now it's estimated 63 63 million this will cost us the cost is of this effort is not in our existing term by capital program and typically these get addressed through the 10-year plan other costs are not including this fiscal note that can have impact in implementation of this aet in our financial model our future implementation of a new back office system.
That's the easy pass back office to handle all the accounts.
There will also be an increase in the back office costs with AET with image review, address lookup, invoices, and sending out violations.
There will also be a potential leakage in all this that we don't get everybody who goes through the toll plaza.
In addition to that, there's also another contract going out for the maintenance of our lane systems out there, which will be another cost to this.
Another thing is we have not included bonding or anything in this for the construction.
And the DOT's recommendation for this is to begin with the AET feasibility study in fall of 2024.
This will allow us to utilize the data from Dover and Rochester implementation and to refine our AET assumptions that were used in those feasibility studies.
And once the study is done, we have the feasibility done, the location, we can come back to legislation for approval.
And then at that point we can lay out a proposed schedule for AET through the 10-year process.
That's all.
Thank you.
Questions?
Representative Thompson.
Thank you.
Questions?
Representative Thompson.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Do you have any statistics on how many people actually pay the cash side of the tolls and how many people are easy pass?
Pres right now is around 30% of cast customers okay all right thank you very much further questions from members of the committee representative clude here Thank you.
Yes, we did lay it out that go into our whole financial model.
With the back office costs and other vendor contracts that are coming up that we don't have.
But planning it now, we can.
I mean, our goal was to do a feasibility study in the future once we get better data from Rochester and Dover.
Because right now, how Rochester and Dover feasibility study in Bedford was done, it was a lot of different assumptions from other states and stuff but people act differently in every other state so that'll give us a good handle on representative Jack thank you mr.
chairman thank you for coming if we were to do this project on the time frame that suggested in the bill it looks to me as though we would be tearing down perfectly serviceable toll booths to put up all electronic tolling.
Is that correct?
Yes.
Any further questions?
If we were to look at this of the 10-year plan, which we'll hear in a couple of weeks.
What would be the department's reaction to that so that we could continue our efforts to look at all electronic towing but not have a standalone bill that sets outside of the 10-year process, which is renewed every two years.
That is the way the department would like to go, is through the 10-year process.
First do the feasibility study, so then we know where the toll plazas will be located, or the gantries, and we can lay the whole project out through the 10-year process.
Is, and I know we don't have the 10-year plan in front of us at the current time, and you may not have the answer, but is there any type of feasibility study for going to AET included in any of the funding in the proposal which we, which we will get sometime this week from the governor.
No, that is not in the 10-year plan right now.
Any further questions?
Thank you.
Appreciate the input.
With that, I will close the public hearing on House Bill 1211.
Mr.
Chairman, this is a technical question.
I'm curious.
We haven't done this for any bills today.
We could, if somebody could get the blue sheet.
The other bigger question, which I have not got a good answer to, is those who have signed up online to support and all they do.
That will get into the file, but I don't have it in front of me right now.
It's the same problem we had a year ago.
If you have a pink card in, you don't have to sign the blue sheet.
Was there anybody on 12-11?
Yeah, thank you Representative Plik, if I could.
House Bill 1211, there was Allen C.
from Loudoun, representing self-representation and is against the bill.
Okay.
We have a few minutes.
I would like to open the executive session on House Bill 1211-FN.
Any discussion, general discussion from the members of the committee on the bill?
Representative Jack.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
My opinion on this bill is pretty much summarized by the question that I asked.
I see no benefit in tearing down perfectly serviceable tollbooths simply because an arbitrary deadline is approaching and so I'm going to be opposed to the bill is that a motion is Is there any other discussion?
Representative Cloutier.
Mr.
Chairman, I've listened to the debate, and I'm going to make the motion of ITL, but I'm going to make a friendly right of friendly burbs.
Originally, I thought this was a good idea, but I think we can incorporate a lot of what Representative Ford, who I commend for bringing to our attention, into the bill, into the 10-year plan, which I think is more proper venue, the more testimony that I see.
So I'm going to move ITL.
Representative Clutier moves ITL.
Is there a second?
I'll second that.
Representative, who?
Oh, Thompson.
Seconds, yeah.
Seconds the bill, there were several.
The motion before us will be any expedient to legislate on House Bill 1211.
Is there any discussion on the motion?
Representative Cloutier.
Thank you.
Further discussion?
I concur with the former chair.
Representative Query.
Yeah, can I just make a friendly reminder to turn on our mics?
Once again, Sue and I are next to the thing and online can't hear as well.
Thank you.
Well, well spoken.
I sometimes don't notice and if they're sitting right away from me, I don't have a problem even without my hearing aids.
I may be the youngest member here, but I am going deaf very quick.
Okay.
Any further discussion?
Seeing none, and the clerk will the roll.
Representative McConkie.
Aye.
Representative Somero.
Representative Fidolfi.
Yes.
Representative Blasek.
Representative Gagne.
Yes.
Representative Thompson.
Representative Boyd.
Boyd votes aye.
Representative Cloutier.
Representative Cloutier votes aye.
Representative Edgar.
Aye.
Representative Tulurski.
Yes.
Clerk votes yes.
Representative Abbott.
Thank you.
Representative Tlurski.
Yes.
Clerk votes yes.
Representative Abbott.
Yes.
Representative Faulkner.
Representative Newman.
Yes.
Representative Eaton.
Aye.
Representative Peterson.
Yes.
Representative Query.
Representative Bunker?
Yes.
Mr.
Chairman?
Yes.
The vote was 19-0 on the motion of an expedient to legislate on House Bill 1211.
Is there any objection to the consent calendar?
Seeing none, it will go on the consent calendar.
We have about seven minutes until our next hearing at 2.15 on House Bill 1449.
If you are going to be testifying on 1449, please fill out a pink card and make sure it makes it up here to the head.
Thank you.
Just as a reminder to everybody who is going to be testifying, I do need a pink card.
And if you submit a pink card, you do not need to sign the blue sheet.
It is one or the other.
Thank you.
The time being 2.15, I will call the public hearing on House Bill 1449FN, enact creating a toll booth exemption for vehicle funeral processions to the Veterans Cemetery in Boscowin, and recognize the prime sponsor, Representative Maureen Mooney, to speak about her bill.
Maureen Mooney, State Representative, State Representative, County District number 21.
I've provided written testimony for everybody on the committee.
So hopefully that's been distributed.
I'm the prime sponsor and a supporter of House Bill 1449 an act creating a toll booth exemption for funeral for vehicle funeral processions to the Veterans Cemetery in Bosco in this bill adds an exemption from tolls on the turnpike system for funeral processions to the New Hampshire State Veterans Cemetery in Boscoen.
The bill is only applicable to funeral homes located in New Hampshire.
The bill was requested by an active member of the Veterans of Foreign Wars as a final and complimentary tribute for those who proudly serve their country I'm sorry.
The bill was requested by an active member of the Veterans of Foreign Wars as a final and complimentary tribute for those who proudly serve their country about to be interred.
As a side note, that individual was planning to be here today.
Unfortunately, he contacted me about 6.30 a.m.
this morning to let me know unexpectedly he could not be here, and he regrets that.
But his story is such, when he explained it to me to introduce this bill, is that his father was interred at the Veterans Cemetery in Boston, and his family and his friends had to pay a toll headed from Merrimack to that cemetery, weighed on him to the extent that he contacted me to sponsor this bill so that other families don't have that inconvenience while making their way to late arrest a loved one in Boscoen.
The bill outlines the process for the toll exemption funeral procession including provisions to notify the Department of Transportation at least 24 hours in advance, having the first vehicle in the procession provided by the funeral director, and all cars in the procession traveling with headlights on.
We respectfully ask that you pass this bill as a proper tribute and recognition of respect for those who served in the United States Armed Forces, as well as their spouses, as they make their final journeys to their resting places.
Thank you all for your attention to this matter, to my testimony and the testimony that will come after me.
And as always, thank you for your service to our state and serving as state representatives.
Thank you Mr.
Chairman that concludes my testimony.
Thank you.
Questions from members of the committee.
Representative Peter.
Hello I'd like to ask a question about implementation.
As time goes on and we have all electronic tolling and no toll collectors, who's going to be looking for the cars with the headlights on?
This is a good question.
And the DOT, I would imagine, would have a better grasp on those plans and when they'll be implemented and so forth.
But as for this bill being effective as quickly as it will, it will be implemented pretty quickly into the toll booths that can maintain and watch out for those processions that have headlights on.
Thank you.
Further questions?
Representative Faulkner.
Thank you.
Further questions?
Representative Faulkner.
Thank you.
This identifies a benefit for New Hampshire funeral homes.
Is it true that the only people buried in the cemetery are residents of New Hampshire or do we take out of state veterans as well?
Thank you.
in the cemetery are residents of New Hampshire, or do we take out of state veterans as well?
I'm going to say that I imagine that that cemetery houses those from all states who may have purchased a plot there or have arranged for a plot there.
However, my familiarity with the logistics of that particular cemetery and who's buried where and so on, I'm not the expert in that area.
Representative Faulkner, I do know the answer.
Because we do use federal money from the VA to do that, any eligible veteran can be buried there.
The vast majority are from New Hampshire, but I do know of others from surrounding areas.
For example, coming from Lowell, it's quicker to get to Bosco than to board on the Cape.
Representative Newman.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Thank you, Representative.
I just want to make sure I heard you said the spouses also of a deceased veteran would qualify under this legislation?
Yes, the legislation mentions the word funeral procession to Boscoen, not being specific as to whether or not the individual who's being buried there is a veteran or a loved one of a veteran.
It's just a person being interred at that cemetery.
Procession, period.
And if I could I follow up?
Follow up.
Thank you.
What is currently being done that you're aware of right now when the processions go?
They would pay a toll.
Thank you.
Any further questions?
Seeing none, thank you very much.
And I would recognize Peter Morin in support of the bill, and he is representing New Hampshire Funeral Directors Association.
Thank you, Chairman Graham and members of the committee.
Everywhere, I want to acknowledge everybody.
My name is Peter Morin.
I am a licensed New Hampshire Funeral Director in Balmer.
I'm also the Executive Director of the New Hampshire Funeral Directors Association.
I've been in that position for 14 years.
I've been in funeral service for well over 20 years here in New Hampshire.
I'm here today on behalf of the association to support House Bill 1449.
And we think this is an honorable gesture to our, an acknowledgement of our veterans and their families.
And the only consideration we had was I'd like to draw your attention to page 1, line 12.
It says, see all vehicles in the funeral procession shall travel with their headlights on.
What we would propose is that as the committee considers and reviews this, is that there is an existing statute already which specifically deals with funeral processions, that is RSA 265 colon 156.
I have copies of that here for the committee which along with my testimony so if you had a reference.
Our thinking was that in order just to pull language, whichever is easiest, whether you would reference that existing statute as far as that or whether you would actually put the language in.
And there's just in the existing statute, it would be 265 colon 156, Roman numeral 2, be the second sentence.
Each vehicle of a funeral procession shall be appropriately marked by having funeral flags or windshield signage and headlights, taillights, and if so equipped, hazard flashers on.
And then a funeral escort or lead vehicle, or funeral lead vehicle, shall use and be equipped with purple flashing or emergency lights.
So there is a statute that's on the, you know, in the books.
It's always been there since 2002.
So just to avoid any future possible confusion.
And I do have copies, as I said, both of the statute and of my own testimony.
And with that, I'd like to thank you.
And in closing, I'd be more than happy to answer any questions or try to answer any questions you might have.
Thank you.
Questions from the committee?
Representative Cloutier.
Yes.
My understanding is like any group of vehicles, I belong to a motorcycle group, and that is we're all responsible for our own tolls, and that there's obviously a photograph taken, and that if you didn't have an easy pass that you would be correct.
Or if they went through the E-ZPass lane and they photographed me, now you're able to pay that online within, I think, seven days.
If you don't have an E-ZPass, you'll get an invoice, I mean, now they have the – you're able to pay that online within, I think, seven days if you don't have an E-ZPass.
You're able to – you'll get an invoice, I believe, from the authority as I understand it.
So there is a system in place, so you don't actually have to give them that dollar or whatever it is.
Yeah.
You're very welcome.
Thank you.
Representative Peters.
Hello.
I have one more implementation question.
If one of the members in the procession has an E-ZPass already in their car, how are they going to know not to charge his E-ZPass and to give them a free ride through?
That's a very good question.
I know when I initially got, and my transponders are sort of vintage now, but they gave me these little envelopes of sleeves.
So like with my motorcycle in that case, I could put, if I was going to be paying it a toll, whatever, you can cover it so it does not, the transponder does not, isn't read by the toll booth.
But I only recently came across those again.
I've never used them.
So I think there is an opportunity for that.
But, yeah, duplication could be an issue.
Any further questions?
Seeing none.
Thank you.
And I would recognize John Corcoran, New Hampshire, Department of Transportation, Turnpikes.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman and the rest of the committee.
My name is John Corcoran.
I'm the Bureau of Turnpike Administrator for the DOT.
I hope to answer some of the questions that people are asking.
First, I'll explain how a funeral procession goes through the toll plaza now typically the lead car from the funeral home will come up to the toll booth they will tell us how many vehicles they have we tell them what the cost is and then the funeral home pays it and then we put the system into we call it convoy mode so any vehicles driving through there don't get charged with their transponder or they don't get an invoice in the mail then if that's typically how happens I will tell you there are some funeral processions that just drive right through where they'll go through the high-speed tolling lanes and they'll end end up getting charged with their E-ZPass or an invoice in the mail.
The DOT has no position on the bill.
We do appreciate the bill and honor the veterans.
We do understand there is some loss of revenue.
That was indeterminable because we're not sure how many funeral processions go up to the Veterans Cemetery.
But we do, there are some concerns in which was brought up in other testimonies.
As we mentioned in the previous bill, we have AET at night.
I don't think a lot of these will be going at night, but we are moving towards AET in Dover and Rochester, and there would be, it'd be very hard to coordinate all that, the free toll and that for those funeral processions.
There would be work on the funeral home and also the individuals who have E-ZPass and stuff, because they will be charged.
And that would be working with our back office vendor to try to get refunded for the toll.
Overall, the bill will create an increase in cost at the administrative time like I was mentioned with the in the easy pass or AET facilities it'll be on us it'll be on the funeral homes too trying to coordinate it in our back office vendor that's.
Thank you.
Questions from the committee to the department?
Representative Newman.
Thank you, Mr.
Cochran.
When you mentioned convoy mode, currently if military vehicles go through, is that what they go through as?
If we could keep the questions to the bill before us.
Okay.
Yes.
Representative Faulkner.
I think this may be a related question, but do you have any provisions for accepting a voucher or other scrip instead of cash or EC pass if, for example, a funeral home wanted to pay that way?
No, we don't have any provisions for something, vouchers or anything like that.
Further questions of the department on this bill?
Representative McConkie.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
And I believe you've already answered this, but I just want to go back to it, if I could, please.
So presently, a procession is going through the toll booth and the funeral director first car would come through and say I have 10 or I have 15.
And then they would be charged for those 15.
Is that what you had said?
Yes.
Okay.
Thank you so much.
Representative Thompson.
Good afternoon, Mr.
Cogren.
Do you have any statistics on how many of those convoy more would you go through in a year?
Hooksup Plaza probably has the most funeral processions to go through, and it's around three per month overall in a year.
Some months it's higher, some months it's lower.
The other plazas, talking to them, they say they usually do it maybe once or twice, if lucky, in a month.
So there's not a lot.
So we're talking maybe 100 a year.
Yeah, maybe, yeah.
Okay.
Thank you very much.
Well, any further questions?
Seeing none, I think my basic question gets back to what one of the prior members was asking about.
how do we and how does the department handle this whole process as we go towards either more open road tolling or all electronic tolling and identifying the vehicles that are going through.
even if we were to pass this bill, how do we prevent the double charging or charging individuals or whatever?
Has the department given any thought at all to how we handle those types of situations?
We thought about it, but it's just too hard to handle it because of people's easy pass and knowing everybody who's in the procession.
It could be the funeral home would have to take care of a lot of it for us to work in, but it would be a big effort.
Representative Query.
Thank you.
I guess going off of that question, when the, say someone goes through a toll without an easy pass, how much of the vehicle is shown?
Is it just the license plate area?
Do you see the whole thing?
So like if someone was reviewing these images, would they be able to tell that this was part of a procession or is there just no way to tell?
No, we only take pictures of the license plates.
That's per law.
So we wouldn't be able to tell the vehicles in a procession or anything.
Thank you.
Any further discussion?
Questions of the department?
Excuse me.
Seeing none, thank you.
I have no further pink cards.
Is anybody who has not testified wishing to testify on House Bill 1449?
Is anybody who has testified once willing or wanting to testify a second time?
Seeing none, I close the public hearing on House Bill 1449.
And I will open the executive session on House Bill 1449FN.
Some general discussion.
First, Representative Faulkner.
Thank you.
I see one problem here.
I'm not surprised that it's made true to this drafting, is that I don't think that we're allowed to change, to treat out-of-state funeral homes differently from in-state funeral homes.
It's a well-established principle that you can't do that.
If you offer it to the public, you can't discriminate across the state boundary.
So I think that's a constitutional flaw here.
Thank you.
Anyone else?
Representative Cleary.
Thank you.
Yeah, I just think this was something that I had when I was reading the bill originally, but it seems I do think if we do go through with this, I would like to see it amended to mirror what's in RSA 265, just because I think headlights alone are not enough of an indicator to be a procession.
Okay.
I tend to agree with that, but it gets even more complicated when the answer that you heard about the law and where they only take pictures of the license plate who is in the procession then becomes a true problem for whoever is sorting this out to sort out.
Any further discussion?
Representative Peterson.
As time goes on and there are no more attendants at the tollboots, I think implementation of this is going to be confusing at best.
We'll never know which cars are which.
So we want to give everybody a free pass, but how do you do it?
That's my concern.
Thank you.
Representative Thompson.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Given that there are possibly 100 of these processions a year that I would guess run anywhere from 10 to 20 cars, and the difficulty in acting this, I just don't see the need for the bill at this point Is that a motion?
Representative Thompson moves inexpedient to legislate on House Bill 1449 FN Is there a second?
Representative Samara seconds the motion of inexpedience to legislate.
Any further discussion?
Seeing none, the clerk will call the roll.
Representative McConkie.
Aye.
Representative Summerhill.
Representative Fidolfi.
Aye.
Representative Blasek.
No.
Representative Blasek votes no.
Representative Gagne.
Aye.
Representative Thompson.
Representative Boyd.
Not here.
Okay.
Representative Cullen.
Aye.
Representative Boyd is not here.
Okay.
Representative Clotter.
Aye.
Representative Edgar.
Representative Talurski.
Yes.
Clerk votes yes.
Representative Abbott.
Yes.
Representative Flockner.
Representative Newman?
Yes.
Representative Eaton?
Aye.
Representative Peterson?
Yes.
Representative Query?
Representative Bunker?
Yes.
Despite being a member of the VFW Eric Leach and all the rest I will vote yes with the vote being 17 to 1 the motion of inexpedient to legislate is adopted it Thank you.
With the vote being 17 to 1, the motion of inexpedient to legislate is adopted.
Is there any objection to the consent calendar?
Seeing none, it will go on the consent calendar to start.
Thank you all.
And we have about five minutes until our next hearing.
Thank you.
If you are planning on testifying on House Bill 1593, I do need a pink card.
We will be starting in about two minutes.
House bill 1593, I do need a pink card.
And while we are waiting, those who made the primary motion on any of the bills do owe me a committee report.
I can wait until tomorrow morning because the calendar is closed and it won't go in the calendar for a few weeks anyways.
But lest I forget about getting them, please turn them in.
Thank you.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
For the record, I'm Representative Peter Somsich.
I represent Ward 3 in Portsmouth.
And I appreciate the chairman and the committee members for letting me introduce this bill.
Just as an aside, I want to say that during the past two years, I watched the chairman as he was very inspired and very passionate about supporting sound barriers for a neighborhood in Bedford.
So I decided to lead by your example and be as passionate to submit this bill today.
So Chairman Graham and committee members, and I've handed out my comments to you already, written comments.
As you can see, I am before you today again advocating for sound barriers for the residents of Panaway Manor and the Rockingham Avenue neighborhoods in Portsmouth, who have been waiting for more than 30 years for the promise that they were given after confirmation that they qualified that such barriers would be installed.
These neighborhoods are currently directly abutting Interstate I-95 and Route 1 bypass roadways.
In addition, one of Portsmouth's middle schools, attended by one-third of all middle schoolers in Portsmouth, the New Franklin School, is sandwiched between both I-95 and Route 1 Bypass.
But these neighborhoods were already there before the expansion of I-95 and Route 1 Bypass occurred.
Those roadways, however, kept on expanding, also generating more and more toll revenues for the state, and are very close neighbors now to the people living and learning in that area.
Allow me to tell you a bit about those neighborhoods.
The residents of the Panaway Manor in Portsmouth have been waiting since the 1980s for noise abatement measures related to I-95 to be undertaken.
As you may know, this neighborhood was built in 1942 to house defense workers for the Portsmouth Naval Shipyard as part of our nation's World War II effort.
The New Franklin School and Rockingham Avenue neighborhoods consist of numerous single-family homes as well as being the home of the New Franklin School.
The students who attend that school suffer from the impacts of the traffic noise, both because classroom windows cannot be open when classes are in session, and also the traffic provides a very high level of noise when children are outside on the playground.
I submitted this bill before the DOT developed its 10-year transportation plan, and I believe most of our needs are actually being included in that transportation plan, which your committee will be hearing next week.
The bill before you does not include, however, a funding plan or a source of new revenue for this purpose.
However, next week I'll be introducing another bill, HB 1656, which will suggest an additional revenue source for the highway fund.
While we are greatly appreciative of the support of the DOT in addressing the majority of our issues in the 10-year transportation plan, we were surprised to learn that the New Frankston School does not qualify for sound barriers because the requirements are based on the road frontage of an impacted area and not what a building is used for.
We respectfully hope that the DOT will reconsider this application used for schools, since a single-family home with four residents, some of whom will not be home most of the day, is certainly not the same as a school with hundreds of students who are there for a long day and also who use the outdoor spaces.
So we would like to see the DOT come up with different requirements for a school property or some property that's used for many individuals instead of just a single-family home.
So thank you very much for listening, and I'd be glad to entertain any questions.
Thank you for your testimony.
And as you know, I thank you for the kind words about my passionate plea for Bedford, but you also know that that bill went down in flames.
So if I can't get it done, we'll see what the committee wants to have done with this one.
But that said, seriously, are there any questions of the representative from members of the committee?
Representative Peters.
In the write-up, they used the words in bold, after confirmation that they qualified.
Does that confirmation criteria that was written back then, 30 years ago, still apply to today's criteria for confirmation to put up a sound barrier?
Thank you, Representative, for that question.
Yes, based on discussions with the DOT, those promises still are the same promises that were made before, obviously by different people, but they are the same requirements.
and these neighborhoods were told at the time, according to all the eyewitnesses from the 1980s, who said, yes, we were told when that happens, we will get barriers.
And maybe money was allocated at the time to do that, but it did not happen.
And based on all their criteria that the DOT has, we do qualify for that.
Any further questions from members of the committee?
Seeing none, thank you.
And I would call Assistant Commissioner from the New Hampshire DOT, Bill Kess, to speak, and the department, or at least Bill, is in opposition to the bill.
Good afternoon, committee.
Thank you for letting me address the bill.
Even though I did sign on the bill in opposition, I think my point is more that it is kind of a redundant bill, as Representative Somsich had noted.
He had introduced the bill before some of the work this summer and fall with the GASA process and the 10-year plan.
and sound walls in Portsmouth for the Panaway Manor and Rockingham Avenue neighborhoods are included.
Part of that is driven by a project that is being developed right now to utilize the shoulders of 95 in advance and over the high-level bridge to ease congestion during summer months.
So with that project, and that's a federal aid project, that can be considered, that can be interpreted as a, what they call a type one project, a project to add capacity, which does require us to evaluate noise impacts and to mitigate those noise impacts associated with that added capacity.
So at the time I think the representative was introducing this bill, we were just completing those, that noise analysis.
And as I said, the results were that Panaway Manor and Rockingham Avenue are eligible.
The New Franklin School, again, based on our longstanding and established policy, and very similar to Tiberi Lane, it didn't have the density.
It did not meet the requirements.
The noise thresholds were met, but the cost reasonableness for our policy weren't met.
So the one other thing, and we assumed when we had done the fiscal note that it was going to be turnpike funded because it is on the turnpike, and we did initially program this with turnpike funds through the 10-year plan process and with the advent of the new infrastructure bill.
and part of the desires of the community to have it done sooner rather than later.
In short, the state funds are down and federal funds are up with the infrastructure bill.
And where it's associated with a federal aid capacity improvement project, we have programmed these sound walls as part of the federal program and to be done beginning in 2023, which is in keeping, I think, with the bill.
So that's all I had, I'd entertain.
Thank you.
Any questions from the committee?
I would ask that since the governor has not transmitted the 10-year transportation plan to us yet, that any questions you ask Mr.
Cass about this is what he has said is in the draft and how it's being handled to take care of what Representative Sonsis has been asking for as far as the sound walls, maybe not all of them, but that.
So please, no extraneous questions on the 10-year plan at this point.
We will have several days of which we can talk to the department about that.
Representative Query.
Thank you.
We will have several days of which we can talk to the department about that.
Representative Query.
Thank you.
My question is just kind of surrounding, so I understand the density is for homes and places of, like, where people live.
is there any mechanism or way that you measure you know more public spaces whether that's parks or recreation areas, or in this case, schools?
Is there a way that you handle those differently, or are they under the same as living areas?
They are.
We We make a calculation to essentially do an equivalency.
And as Representative Somsich noted, it is kind of based on the lineal foot of frontage.
So that frontage along the highway and the various spaces or uses are converted into an equivalent number of receptors that would be benefited.
Does that answer your question?
Yeah.
Any further questions of the department on this bill?
Representative Newman.
Yes.
Thank you.
Mr.
Kass, is there any, in your experience with trying to accommodate sound barriers, is there any other area that has waited more than 30 years, or is this like the longest one?
The short answer is I don't know.
Certainly that neighborhood has been there, and the interstate through there was originally built in the early 70s.
I'm sure there are other areas.
You had referenced the one in Tiberi Lane.
The Central New Hampshire Turnpike had been there since the 50s.
It was widened with the Airport Access Road in the late 1990s.
So I don't know if there are any, but there are, part of our assessment, there are a number of places in a similar condition as Panaway Manor that are adjacent to a highway, have noise impacts, may have been there preceding the highway, but there isn't a capacity improvement.
There isn't a project in the area there that warrants or allows us to look at sound barriers.
So we did an assessment, and there are, you know, I think we identified 48 or 50 other areas around the state that have maybe not the same degree but are in a similar situation.
And if it was elected to try to mitigate noise at all of those, it was a substantial dollar amount.
So a big part of what we look at with our policy is trying to treat everybody kind of the same and equitable.
That's behind some of the cost reasonableness as well.
Representative Faulkner.
The question I have is looking at what might be the source of people's belief that there was a promise here.
Were these sound barriers presented as a mitigation measure and an environmental assessment or some similar documentation that we can look to, or is it basically conversations that people might have had?
You put me in an awkward position here.
I didn't want to necessarily refute that, but it has been brought up in the past, and as far as I know, there weren't any promises made.
I mentioned the time frame because, granted, that neighborhood was there long before the interstate.
The interstate was built in the early 70s.
I think Spalding Turnpike work was done in around the 80s.
The federal requirements in the department didn't have a noise policy relative to noise abatement until the early, mid-1990s.
So I can't verify that there was any promises made or anything like that, but I do know in that time frame, we really weren't looking at, it wasn't a requirement, it wasn't something that was looked at in terms of noise abatement.
The first noise barriers, sound abatement that I know we installed were part of the Nashua Central Turnpike widening that was begun in the mid-1990s, and that's when the issue of noise abat stuff first became something that we started to address.
Representative Edgar.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Okay, stay on.
Thank you for taking this question, Assistant Commissioner.
it appears that, or I guess to me the question I have is, there seem to be like three areas that are associated in the area of this new project in Portsmouth, and is it that there's two of them will qualify for your present standards?
I don't have the full report in front of me.
There were more than these three areas that have been mentioned that were evaluated.
We evaluated the whole area, and I think there were six or seven, I think we identified eight or nine areas.
Some of them ran together, so there were probably, and I can get the exact number, but I think there were like six or seven that were evaluated.
And of those, the two that we've mentioned, Pannoy Manor and Rockingham Avenue, did meet the criteria, and the other ones, including the New Franklin School, did not.
Okay.
And I'm not as familiar.
Oh, excuse me, Mr.
Chairman, if I continue.
Thank you.
With the Franklin School, is it actually in the area of this new project?
Yes, it's right adjacent to 95, right.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Now, one of the 10-year plan hearings I was at, it was mentioned that the kids can't even play outside for recess because of the noise.
I just want to know how you fit that into your criteria for importance to be able to meet the criteria.
Thank you very much.
Sure.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
Yeah, no, like I said, you know, we look at the frontage.
I mean, there is a calculation equivalently determined.
We look at it's not based on the number of students or people there, but it's looked at the lineal frontage along the turnpike and equated into a number of receptors for the outdoor areas.
So I know there's a playground, there's a ball field, and there's several areas there.
So based on that, there was an equivalency for a number of receptors.
But again, just the long spread out frontage of it makes it difficult to reach the cost effectiveness criteria.
Thank you.
Any further questions?
Representative Thompson.
Good afternoon, Commissioner Cass.
Has there been any other – I'm not an engineer.
I've spent my whole life in the construction business, but I'm not an engineer.
Are there any other considerations given to other methods of producing these sound barriers other than the million-dollar tag that's hooked to this one?
And I specifically refer to...
From time to time, you folks have excess material on your highway projects, and you build berms generally in the median from those excess materials.
Why couldn't that be done in some of these areas if the right of way is wide enough?
It certainly wouldn't allow a barrier to be used as a graffiti site.
And it would be a no-maintenance solution to the problem.
It seems like there should be other considerations given to some of these areas that...
Is there a question here?
Yeah, usually we do.
Usually we look real hard to try to make it meet the criteria.
And usually from our screening, if it's way far apart, we're not going to meet the criteria.
If it's close, if it's just over or even near, that's when we will look a lot harder at either berms or berms in conjunction with walls, lowering, you know, having partial berm, partial wall on top of it to make it as cost effective as possible.
And there are areas where standalone berms do work, and there is area and there is room, and we have built those.
There's an area in Nashua, just south of the Merrill's Marauders Bridge, where we did berm up and built berms there.
I can tell you in the Portsmouth area, the berms would not be effective because it is very dense.
It's the turnpike, the fence, and all these neighborhoods, and a berm wouldn't fit.
But we do look primarily to reduce the cost, whether it's a berm standalone or at least berming up some of the materials so the wall height is less and as cost effective as possible.
Any further questions of the department on this bill?
Representative Cloutier.
Now?
Okay, good.
I'm sorry.
Still getting used to these mics.
Thank you.
Okay, good.
I'm sorry.
Still getting used to these mics.
Thank you.
In regards to this bill, as far as funding, is the described project in this bill, do you know, does it qualify for any funding from the recently passed bipartisan infrastructure plan, even though it's on a turnpike?
Yes, it does.
Thank you.
qualify for any funding from the recently passed bipartisan infrastructure plan, even though it's on a turnpike?
Yes, it does.
It does qualify.
Yes.
Okay.
And a follow-up, please, Mr.
Chairman.
Do sound barriers built along interstate highways, do they also qualify for funding under the recently bipartisan infrastructure plan?
Yes.
In keeping with our policy.
In other words, they do qualify for federal funding, but they still need to meet the criteria established in the noise mitigation policy.
Okay.
A further question, please, Mr.
Chairman.
Does that include the standard?
Is the standard the same for both turnpikes and interstate highways?
They've got to meet certain criteria.
Yes, yeah.
We have one policy, and it's based on the federal guidelines, and it's applied consistently whether it's state turnpike-funded or federally funded.
Okay.
So just to be clear, a final question, Mr.
Chairman.
So it's clear the policy is the same.
whether a sound barrier was built along a turnpike or an interstate highway could qualify for funding under the recent, whatever the state gets from the recently passed a bipartisan infrastructure plan.
Yes, that's right.
Okay.
Thank you very much for your question.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
You're welcome.
Any other questions?
I do have one clarifying question before we close out here.
Listening to what both the sponsor and you have said sitting there, the vast majority of what is being asked for in this bill will be presented to us as part of the 10-year plan.
Is that correct?
Yes.
It is, yes.
Thank you.
That might clarify some questions people have on how they wanna handle this bill.
Has anybody not testified wishing to testify?
I see none.
Is anybody who testified once want to testify again and it better be very short?
Yes, Representative Sons Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
I just wanted to respond to Representative Thompson's question, which I think was a really good question.
I'm a material scientist by training, and I wanted to just let you know that the Panaway Manner neighborhood used to be surrounded by a lot of trees.
And they all got cut down when the expansion happened.
And when that happened, the noise level went up right away.
So trees do something, do help.
But I also want to mention that in Denmark now, there are several companies now that are taking old generation wind turbine blades and chopping them up and using them very effectively for noise abatement.
Thank you.
There being no other testimony on this bill, I will close the public hearing on House Bill 1593.
I will now open the executive session on House Bill 1593, the act requiring Department of Transportation to elect Soundberry as on Interstate 95 in the City of Portsmouth.
Any general discussion from members of the committee?
Seeing none, And what is from members of the committee?
Seeing none, what is the pleasure of the committee in regards to this bill?
Somebody say something.
Representative McConkie.
Mr.
Chairman, understanding that much of this is going to be forthcoming in the 10-year plan when it's revealed, and the parts, as I understand, don't meet the standard, I move ITL.
Representative McConkie moves inexpedient to legislate on House Bill 1593.
Is there a second?
Representative Eaton seconds the motion of inexpedient to legislate.
I will say that I am going to vote in favor of inexpedient to legislate, and I would ask that the sponsor work closely with DOT as we go forward through the 10-year process to make sure that his desires continue to be known as well as those of his constituents.
You may not win much more, but at least you've gotten some progress.
Is there any other discussion on the bill?
Representative Cloutier.
Thank you.
Any further comments or discussion on the motion of inexpedient to legislate?
Representative Query.
I'll make this really quick.
Just to further from Representative Cloutier's point, we heard testimony last session from someone who said that she'd been working on this since 1993, before I was even born.
So I'm very glad to see that this is finally making it somewhere.
But I think something that I will be working on over the summer, and if I am honored enough to be reelected and put back on this committee, I think something that we should work towards is readjusting how we qualify for sound barriers.
I think there are some oversights just because of the times, and there are some concerns with, as we move towards electric vehicles, how those different vehicles will cause different sound issues.
Thank you.
Representative Jack.
Mr.
Cass, isn't it true that these are federal regulations and so the state is not at liberty to modify the criteria?
Please come up because this is being live streamed and people need to be able to hear what you're saying.
Yes and no.
Not to be confusing, but to be precise, there are federal regulations.
It is a federal regulation that we need to have a sound, a noise policy.
The specifics of that noise policy, we do have some discretion on how the thresholds are established and things like that.
And I think, Representative Graham, you know that there were, in past years, I forget how many years ago, there were study commissions to look at some of those.
And for instance, I remember providing some of the testimony, there are some states that have very lenient thresholds.
There are some that have very stringent thresholds.
And I think we, New Hampshire, fell kind of in the middle of the pack there.
So, yes, it is a federal requirement to have a policy, but some of the elements of the policy are at our discretion.
But it is a requirement to establish some of those criterias and apply them uniformly and consistently so there's not perceptions of favoritism from one area of the state or one community to the other.
So that's what we try to do is apply it consistently.
Thank you, Representative Faulkner.
And we're not reopening all the questioning.
Okay.
Okay, there you go.
I tried it before.
We saw that there's a whole list of projects, especially those that are not associated with a current highway improvement project, and that we need to have some mechanism for setting priorities that is objective and not whoever yells the loudest or has the friends in high places or whatever.
I think that doing this in a way that is systematic and fair to everybody is important.
I would agree with that.
And I think representative query has a good point of at some point we need to relook at what the criteria within the state of New Hampshire is for sound walls and where we will spend the money on them.
But that is not what we are looking at today.
And we can discuss that tomorrow or during any of our work sessions with DOT on the 10-year plan on what the criteria is and how it gets changed.
But right now we have a motion in front of us of inexpedient to legislate on House Bill 1593.
Any further discussion on the motion?
Seeing none, the clerk will call the roll.
Representative McConkie.
Aye.
Representative Summerhill.
Representative Fidolfi.
Yes.
Representative Blasek.
Representative Gagney.
Yes.
Representative Thompson.
Representative Blasek?
Yes.
Representative Gagney?
Representative Thompson?
Yes.
Representative Boyd is still not here.
Representative Cloutier?
Yes.
Representative Edgar?
Aye.
Representative Talersky?
Yes.
Clerk votes yes.
Representative Abbott?
Yes.
Representative Faulkner?
Representative Newman?
Yes.
Representative Eaglen?
Representative Newman?
Yes.
Representative Eaton?
Aye.
Representative Peterson?
Yes.
Representative Query?
Representative Bunker?
Yes.
And Mr.
Chairman?
Yes.
The vote being 18 to 0, the motion of inexpedient to legislate.
The vote being 18 to 0, the motion of inexpedient to legislate is adopted.
Is there any objection to the consent calendar?
Seeing none, it will go on the consent calendar, and I thank everybody for their attention on this bill.
Before I say we're finished for the day, I would like to remind everyone that we start at 930 tomorrow morning.
We have three which could be contentious bills, two dealing with the sale of the Lakes region facility and one dealing with state funds for new passenger rail.
It is my intention not to exact any of those three bills tomorrow, because no matter what we do, we're going to have to have more thoughtful discussion and maybe amendments to any of them as we go forward.
So I would rather put that off after people have thought about it and looked.
So we will not have any executive sessions tomorrow.
And then in the afternoon, we will be hearing an orientation from the department on the 10-year plan and available funding, how it was developed, not necessarily everything that's in it because the governor still has it, and he has until the end of the week to give it to the legislature.
But it will be useful for all of us to know what funds were available, what funds became available from the federal government, and how they were utilized, as we just found out today.
They can be partially used for sound walls.
But there's lots of other uses they can be used for, too.
So that's why I've asked for the department to spend as much time in the afternoon as the committee wants.
For those of you who will not be able to be here, remember it is live streamed.
You can watch it, and the department will be sending out their presentation to all the members of the committee.
So you will have a copy tonight.
All right.
Okay.
Never mind.
I don't check my email while I'm sitting here.
So it is already out in your hands.
So that's helpful.
And it will be a good start for when we begin process on other bills that deal with funding and the 10-year plan.
So thank you all.
Representative Abbott.
Yes, I just wondered, Mr.
Chairman, if it's all right if we leave our papers here.
Yeah, we'll be back in the same room tomorrow.
but after we leave tomorrow, whenever you leave tomorrow, we will have to clean up because state and federal is in here on Friday.
Representative Gagne.
Try it again.
I've left the representative's stuff here.
It's good.
It's good because the committee assistant will make sure it gets into the right place.
That's fine, too.
I mean, he'll probably ask, but it's fine.
Representative Clear?
Clear?
Do we have drawers assigned to us yet in there?
Yes.
Anything else for me or for the rest of the committee?
If not, I will see you all bright and early tomorrow.
I thank you all for your patience and work today.
We got a lot of work done.
So I appreciate it, and we can keep moving on.
Thank you.